das panel könnte im jahr 2000 167 auf
die erde stürzen die folgen wären fatal
konkrete details über bänder sind uns
bislang nicht bekannt doch das könnte
sich schon bald ändern denn derzeit geht
die mission um die raumsonde osiris rex
nach zwei jahren anreise in die heiße
phase jetzt mitte august sollen die
ersten bilder geschossen werden und im
dezember soll dann die ernährungs phase
erfolgreich abgeschlossen sein dann wird
die sonde auf dem asteroiden landen und
proben mit zur erde bringen wie die
mission genau geplant ist was die proben
des astro ihnen über ihn verraten können
und wie so ein möglicher
asteroideneinschlag eben gut 150 jahren
verhindert werden soll jetzt bei klicks
und science fiction herzlich willkommen
[Musik]
ihr könnt jetzt übrigens mitglied
hierbei klicks um auf youtube werden
dafür gibt es einen extra video einen
privat livestream nur für euch und noch
ein paar privilegien wie zum beispiel
extra images dafür habe ich mich
ziemlich ins zeug gelegt aber dazu am
ende des videos mehr um es mal direkt
auf den punkt zu bringen einem
asteroideneinschlag sind wir genau wie
das restliche leben auf der erde einfach
nur schutzlos ausgeliefert ihr könnt
euch alle ausmalen was bei einem arzt zu
ihnen anschlag auf der erde passieren
könnte holly und filme dazu gibt es ja
genug fliegende trümmer tsunami wellen
und schlimme erdbeben etwa könnten einen
großteil des lebens auf der erde
auslöschen den riesen brocken benno
ideen zählt die nasa zu den
gefährlichsten aller bekannten
asteroiden berechnungen zufolge könnte
er bei einem vorbeiflug am 25 september
2001 135 der erde tatsächlich gefährlich
nahe kommen näher als der erde und das
wiederum könnte seine weitere flugbahn
so verändern dass er noch im selben jahr
100 mit der erde kollidiert dazu der
forscher patrick mittel vom pariser
observatorium wenn s bahn haben wir bis
ins jahr 2035 vorausberechnet dann wird
er sich der erde bis auf ungefähr 280
1000 kilometer annähern
danach ist ein weiterer kurs unsicher da
er davon abhängt wie nah er der erde
wirklich kommt und wie stark sie seine
bahn verändert unseren analysen zufolge
könnte er beim nächsten mal im jahr 2001
67 mit einer wahrscheinlichkeit von 1 zu
2700 auf der erde einschlagen
eine studie aus 2009 berechnete eine
serie von möglichen zusammenstößen mit
der erde zwischen 2169 und 2199 doch die
genaue wahrscheinlichkeit für eine
kollision ist wie gesagt nicht wirklich
zu beziffern
denn die physikalischen eigenschaften
des asteroiden sind noch weitestgehend
unbekannt eine version mit bühne hätte
mit seinem durchmesser von 500 metern
und einem gewicht von 87 millionen
tonnen jedenfalls fatale folgen bei
einem aufprall würde er nach
berechnungen der nasa wohl eine energie
von 80.000 atombomben freisetzen
das entspricht einer kinetischen energie
von 1200 megatonnen und schreiben also
nur 100 jahre um gegenmaßnahmen für
diesen möglichen asteroideneinschlag zu
erarbeiten
wir hatten in diesem zusammenhang der
bereits über die idee der nasa werde
planetary die fans team berichtet
stichwort hemmer
das steht für high velocity sj
mitigation mission for emergency
response wege ein neun meter langes und
knapp neun tonnen schweres raumschiff
das mit einer delta 4 mw in den weltraum
gebracht werden soll es könnte nicht nur
als transportmittel für eine atombombe
dienen sondern auch als rammbock
beispielsweise eben für bennet denn ein
kleiner schubs sagt könnte den
asteroiden zu einer kursänderung bringen
doch das ist nicht die einzige strategie
an der forschungsteams weltweit tüfteln
um uns verbindet zu schützen
denn derzeit wird es auch um die
raumsonde osiris rex die auf dem
asteroiden benny landen soll extrem
spannend jetzt soll sich die sonne so
angenähert haben das erste fotos gemacht
werden können und auch sonst sind die
erwartungen an die mission alles andere
als klein astronomie teams hoffen auf
überlebenswichtige erkenntnisse für die
menschheit dazu alexander may ingenieur
bei lockheed martin space systems
company die die sonde im auftrag der
nasa gebaut hat es haben bereits einige
untersuchungen des asteroiden aus der
ferne stattgefunden werden ihn sowohl
mit rada als auch mit optischen
teleskope von der erde aus beobachtet
unsere wissenschaftler haben einige
vermutungen woraus das objekt besteht
und wie groß das genau ist wir glauben
wenn er ist der perfekte ort um eine
proben enden
arme durchzuführen der plan sieht vor
zunächst die geologische zusammensetzung
von bennett zu untersuchen um zu wissen
wie porös und kompakt der brocken
wirklich ist die annäherung an den
riesen brocken soll so vorsichtig wie
möglich passieren dann wird das erste
wissenschaftliche instrument eingesetzt
die politik hat die aufgabe pendelzug
kartografiert theoretisch ist die kamera
in der lage objekte in der größe eines
kieselstein zu erfassen
im dezember soll die sonde dann so nahe
bei dem asteroiden sein dass seine
schwerkraft gegen die anziehungskraft
der sonne gewinnt osirix 6 wird dann in
eine umlaufbahn von benny einschwenken
die sonde soll sich dann auch auf das
schwerefeld des asteroiden genauer
anschauen besteht der brocken er aus
gestein oder ist er ein objekt das sich
aus losem und porösem material mit viel
staub zusammensetzt auch das ist eine
info die für das leben auf der erde im
ernstfall von immenser bedeutung sein
könnte doch auch andere super spannende
erkenntnisse könnte uns die probe von
ben bescheren dazu osiris rex forscher
umberto kamp ins diese primitiven hast
du jeden verfügen über einen hohen
anteil organischer moleküle wenn wir
verstehen wollen wie das leben auf der
erde und vielleicht anderswo entstanden
ist müssen wir die zusammensetzung
solche asteroiden verstehen die
probenentnahme selbst ist allerdings
erst für in zwei jahren geplant dann
steht der rückflug zur erde an und der
dauert wohl bis 2023 und das neueste ihr
könnt mitglied hier auf dem kanal werden
und neben ein paar privilegien gibt es
dann nur für euch exklusiv an extra
video und einen privat livestream
einfach auf mitglied werden hier unter
dem video klicken wenn ihr kein video
zum thema soliden anschläge und zu allen
anderen themen verpassen wollt dann
hättet mich bei whatsapp dann umgeht er
die etwas unzuverlässige abo boxer auf
youtube und er verpasst kein video weil
ihr dort vorab garantiert informiert
werdet einfach hier draufklicken und am
besten auch mal ein schwesterkanal krieg
zum social media abonnieren dafür ihr
klicken aber nicht die genau die glocke
vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit
dafür auch draufklicken gefährlichster
akteur nasa rammbock gegen benno bis
dann bleibt dran